من سربهم لماذا تم تسريبهم كم
عدد الأسرار المفقودة ، هذه هي
الأسئلة الرئيسية الجديدة هذا الصباح حيث
يتدافع البنتاغون للسيطرة على الضرر
بعد أن ظهرت وثائق سرية للغاية
على الإنترنت وقد استعرضت سي إن إن 53 من
هذه الوثائق يبدو أن جميعها قد تم
إنتاجها فيما بين
كشف
مصدر مقرب من الرئيس الأوكراني
فلاديمير زيلينسكي لشبكة CNN أن أوكرانيا قد
غيرت بالفعل بعض
خططها العسكرية بسبب هذه التسريبات ،
مراسلة CNN للأمن القومي ناتاشا.
ينضم بيرتراند إلينا الآن على الهواء مباشرة من
البنتاغون ناتاشا ما الذي تتعلمه
عن مصدر هذه الوثائق
وكيف تستجيب الإدارة
جون إنه حقًا ما
نتعلمه هو أن هذه المستندات ظهرت لأول مرة
على منصة وسائط اجتماعية
تسمى تجاهل Discord على الأقل
قبل شهر وكان هناك ما لا يقل عن 50 منهم
راجعتها CNN وجميعهم
لديهم علامات سرية بما في ذلك بعض ما يصل
إلى مستوى سري للغاية وهو
أعلى مستوى من التصنيف في
الحكومة الأمريكية الآن تقوم وزارة
العدل الأمريكية بالتحقيق في الأمر.
بناءً على إحالة من البنتاغون
التي أحالت الأمر إلى
وزارة العدل ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي لإجراء مزيد من
التحقيق ليلة الجمعة ، لكن انظر إلى
هذه الوثائق تحتوي على
معلومات حساسة بشكل لا يصدق حول
نقاط القوة والضعف في تحركات القوات الأوكرانية
بما في ذلك نقاط الضعف في
دفاعاتها الجوية بالإضافة إلى أنها مهمة حقًا  ومعلومات
جديدة حول المدى الذي
تمكن مجتمع الاستخبارات الأمريكي من
الوصول إليه في اختراق وزارة الدفاع الروسية
بالإضافة إلى
منظمة المرتزقة الروسية Wagner Group
التي تقوم بالطبع أيضًا بتنفيذ
عمليات في أوكرانيا الآن
نتعلم أيضًا من هذه الوثائق أن
تأتي هذه المعلومات الواردة في هذه
المستندات السرية للغاية من مجموعة متنوعة من
الوكالات المختلفة عبر حكومة الولايات المتحدة
بما في ذلك وكالة المخابرات المركزية وكذلك
وكالة الاستخبارات الدفاعية ، وبالتالي
فقد أثر هذا حقًا على الكثير من
الوكالات المختلفة عبر الحكومة
بالإضافة إلى العديد من  يوضح
أقرب حلفاء الولايات المتحدة ، بما في ذلك إسرائيل
وكوريا الجنوبية ، الكثير من هذه الوثائق بالتفصيل
تنصت الولايات المتحدة واعتراض
اتصالات هؤلاء الحلفاء الأجانب الذين
يتحدثون مع بعضهم البعض ، لذلك من الواضح أنه
سيكون هناك بعض الاحتكاك هنا
للمضي قدمًا بين الولايات المتحدة
والحلفاء الذين يتحدثون بالفعل.
لهؤلاء الحلفاء وإجراء
تقييم للضرر ، جون حول كيفية تأثير هذه البحيرة على
الأمن القومي.
صحيح وأنت
تتحدث عن نوع من النطاق الذي
أتت منه هذه المعلومات المسربة ،
فلنتعمق قليلاً في
ما تم الكشف عنه في هذه
الوثائق العديد من الوثائق المسربة
حيث كانت ناتاشا تتحدث عن صفقة مع
حرب روسيا على  أوكرانيا ، بما في ذلك
المعلومات الاستخبارية عن كلا البلدين ،
توضح وثيقة سرية واحدة من فبراير / شباط
تناقص مخزونات الصواريخ التي
تمتلكها أوكرانيا ، وتتضمن أيضًا
تسليمًا تقديريًا لأنظمة أسلحة إضافية
وخطط تدريب
الجنود الأوكرانيين على تلك الأنظمة ، والآن
تُظهر وثيقة أخرى الاستراتيجيات العسكرية المقترحة
لأوكرانيا اللوجستية  والتوصيات المتعلقة
بالسياسة العامة للدولة
بالنسبة لأوكرانيا ، هناك وثيقة أخرى تم تمييزها بأنها سرية
للغاية وتحتوي على
معلومات حول
أحجام الكتيبة الروسية والأوكرانية ومواقعها
بالإضافة إلى مستوى خسائر ساحة المعركة التي
تكبدها كلا الجانبين
يعتقد المسؤولون الأمريكيون أن الخسارة قد تم
توضيحها.  في هذا المستند على
وجه الخصوص ، ربما تم تغييره لإظهار عدد
أقل من الضحايا الروس مقارنة
بالوثائق الأخرى المقدرة التي تظهر مدى
عمليات الشراء الأمريكية في كوريا الجنوبية
وإسرائيل بما في ذلك فيما يتعلق
بكوريا الجنوبية محادثة بين اثنين من كبار
مسؤولي الأمن القومي الكوري الجنوبي
حول مخاوفهم بشأن  طلب أمريكي
للحصول على ذخيرة سيتم إرسالها إلى
أوكرانيا ، يناقش هؤلاء المسؤولون طريقة
للالتفاف على سياسة الدولة المتمثلة في عدم
تقديم مساعدات مميتة إلى دول في حالة حرب ،
وعندما يتعلق الأمر بإسرائيل ، فإن بعض
هذه الوثائق المسربة أثارت
غضبًا في استخبارات الدولة
تجمعوا يزعمون فيه أن
جهاز المخابرات الإسرائيلي ،
الموساد ، كان يشجع الاحتجاجات
ضد الحكومة الجديدة للبلاد ، وأن
مكتب رئيس الوزراء قد خرج بالفعل
ونفى بشكل قاطع أن التقييم الذي
انضم إلي الآن ، هناك الكثير هنا ولكن
انضم إلي للحصول على المزيد حول هذا
الملازم  الجنرال مارك مارك يندفع
للمحللين العسكريين في شبكة سي إن إن ، جنرال ، وضعنا
فقط بعضًا مما تم الكشف عنه في
هذه الوثائق ، ما هو أكثر إشكالية
في هذه التسريبات من وجهة نظرك
ما قلته قبل دقيقة واحدة فقط كيت هو
الأكثر إشكالية هناك الكثير منهم
وهم  عبر اللوح ولكن ما
يضيف إليه أيضًا أنه يختلف عن
التسريبات السابقة التي كنت تعرف أن وثائق
مثل Snowden تسربت في الأسبوع إلى
Wikileaks وهي عبارة عن قطع
ورقية موثقة تروي القصة ما
يفعله هؤلاء وما رأيناه من بعض
هم ربما يقدمون توجيهًا خاطئًا أو
معلومات مضللة ، لقد
أعيد تصميمهم لإظهار أشياء مختلفة عن
المستندات الأصلية التي نعرفها
بالفعل ، لذا فهي مزيج من
البيانات الحية الحقيقية أسرار حية حقيقية كما
قالت ناتاشا برتراند إنها قالت إن
بعضها سري للغاية  ولكن في بعض هذه
الوثائق يقولون إنها سرية للغاية لا أجنبي
مما يعني أنه لا يوجد
نشر أجنبي وهذا هو العلامة الموجودة
في الجزء العلوي من تلك الوثائق ، لذا فهي ليست فقط
نوع المعلومات الاستخبارية التي نجمعها عن الأعداء
ولكن أيضًا نوع المعلومات الاستخباراتية التي
تجمعها جميع الدول  على
أصدقائهم أيضًا ، نقوم بذلك أيضًا ، لكن الدول الأخرى تفعل
ذلك أيضًا ولكنك لا تحب أن يتم وضعها
في الفضاء العام ، فأنت تصطدم
بشيء أردت أن أسألك عنه
لأنه إذا كنت تقوم بذلك
مثل المنظور ، فهذا شيء واحد إذا
لم يتم تسريب المعلومات الاستخباراتية أبدًا
شيئًا جيدًا ، ولكن إذا تم تسريب معلومات استخباراتية
حول برنامج تمرير أو
استراتيجية أو عملية أوسع ، فإن ما ننظر
إليه هنا بمعنى أننا نحصل عليه
في رد الفعل عليه هو ما  هل هذا
يعني أنه في الوقت الفعلي ، عام عندما
يتعلق التسرب بمستويات العرض
والقدرات في حرب جارية ،
نعم مرة أخرى سأقارنه بـ
Wikileaks قبل عامين والتي
حدثت ، كانت تلك الجداول والأشياء
التي كانت تسير فيما بينها  السفارات
ولديها مشاكل تخطيط طويلة الأمد ولكن عندما
تتحدث عن اليوم أه
الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا ، أه
نية لدعم شركائنا في المملكة المتحدة الأوكرانيين
بالمعدات
والإمدادات بخرائط المعركة التي
تحدث أه تعلمون خلال
الأسبوع الماضي أو  في اليومين الأخيرين ، تعرف أن
هؤلاء يقدمون حياة حقيقية قريبة في آه ذكاء في الوقت المناسب
لعدو وهذا ليس
جيدًا آه من المؤسف أن هذا قد
حدث بهذه الطريقة ولكن
من الصدق أيضًا أن كيت تتعرض لسوء فهم من قبل
العديد من الأشخاص الذين لا يفهمون ما
في  هذه المستندات وسأقول أن
نيويورك تايمز قامت بعمل قطعة بالأمس حيث
وضعوا حرفياً شريحتين من The
Joint Staff داخل مقالتهم دون
وصف لما كنت تعرفه عندما
قرأت عندما نظرت إلى الشريحتين اللتين
تم تشغيلهما  فريق العمل المشترك بمجرد أن
عرفت بالضبط ما كان يقوله ولم
يكن يقول نفس الشيء الذي كان
في تقرير الصحيفة ، لذلك ستحصل على
محللي تحليل Intel الهواة
يقولون أشياء ليست صحيحة
بشأن بعض هذه المستندات ولكن  هذا
لا يقلل من أه
عامل الخوف المتورط في هذه الأشياء التي
تتسرب إلى عامة الناس
بسرعة حقيقية ما الذي يحتاجه الجيش الأمريكي
الآن للتخفيف من
الضرر الناجم عن هذه الغرامة
التي سربها أولاً وقبل كل
شيء و  لقد فعلوا ذلك من خلال مخاطبتها
مع وزارة العدل
ولكن هناك أيضًا بعض النظرات الداخلية حول
كيفية ظهور هذه الأشياء
لدي بعض الأفكار بعد أن عملت في
البنتاغون حول ما يمكن أن يحدث ولكن
يتعين عليهم أيضًا إجراء
تقييمات سريعة حقًا  ليس فقط الجيش الأمريكي
ولكن أيضًا الجيوش في جميع أنحاء العالم
والحكومات في جميع أنحاء العالم ، يتعين عليهم
سحب محللي Intel من وظائفهم العادية
مما يأخذهم بعيدًا عما
يفعلونه عادةً
ويقولون ما هو تقييم الضرر
لهذه الأشياء  ربط ما يمكن أن يحدث
لأن الناس يرون ما هو موجود في هذه
الوثائق أو يعرفون عن المصادر
والطرق أه كل هذه الأشياء
مهمة وكل هذه الأشياء كلها
تحدث بشكل واضح ونحن نتحدث
عامة شكرا جزيلا لك